Halloween is fast approaching, and it's bringing
a ton of new horror movies to terrify you.
Here's how the theaters will trick and treat
you this Halloween.
The Nun
The Conjuring Universe is screaming back into
theaters with The Nun, which will add some
backstory to one of Conjuring 2's most terrifying
characters.
A priest joins forces with a young nun in
Romania to investigate a death at a remote,
probably haunted abbey in the mountains.
You can bet they'll come face to face with
a few unholy horrors creeping around those
dark hallways.
And they are having nun of it.
American Horror Story's Taissa Farmiga plays
the lead, with Bonnie Aarons returning as
the demonic nun Valak.
The Nun will return to scare the pew out of
you on September 7th.
Mandy
When critics rave that Nicolas Cage gave "the
performance of a lifetime," you know it's
something special.
"So what you hunting?
"It's Crazy evil!"
From writer-director Panos Cosmatos, Mandy
is a tale of backwoods revenge that pushes
the horror envelope in ways few filmmakers
would even attempt.
Red and Mandy lead an isolated existence deep
in the woods.
That is, until Mandy breaks that cardinal
rule of camping she attracts the attention
of a psychotic cult leader.
Obviously, things go bad, leading Red to embark
on a spree of drug-fueled vengeance.
Behold the insanity when Mandy debuts September
14th.
Halloween
Remakes and reboots of classic horror franchises
haven't exactly been cinematic gold in recent
years, but Halloween might be the horror movie
that finally, violently breaks the mold.
Eastbound & Down star Danny McBride and producer
David Gordon Green came together to work on
the concept for the new film, which they pitched
directly to the franchise's original creator
John Carpenter, who loved it, even though
he never wanted a sequel in the first place.
Why this time?
"It's pretending the other sequels didn't
happen."
This new film takes place after the events
of the 1978 original, and judging by the trailers,
Halloween is going to be pure terror.
Take a look when it hits theaters on October
19th.
Overlord
A World War II-set horror outing from J.J.
Abrams' Bad Robot production company, Overlord
asks the question: what's worse than dropping
into a German-filled warzone?
Simple: dropping into a German-filled warzone
along with goopy zombie-monsters.
The movie follows some American paratroopers
who land in German-occupied France and find
themselves fighting for their lives against
bloodthirsty monsters.
Since this is a Bad Robot production, it wasn't
long before rumors started flying that Overlord
was yet another stealth entry in the Cloverfield
universe.
Despite the speculation, J.J. Abrams says
it definitely isn't.
And that's totally okay: a World War II survival
horror movie sounds like a great time all
by itself.
Check it out when Overlord premieres on November
9th.
The Predator
The original Predator immersed audiences in
an exciting blend of sci-fi, action, and horror,
and the sequel looks like it's going back
to those terrifying roots.
Co-writer and director Shane Black promises
that The Predator will carry a hard R rating,
giving the alien hunter free reign to do what
it does best: take loads of guys.
The film's suburban setting should provide
even more opportunities for thrills, because
the scariest monster is the one in your own
backyard… and we don't mean your Weird Uncle
Charlie.
Activate your heat vision and look for The
Predator in theaters on September 14th.
Venom
While it may not be a horror movie in the
classic sense, Venom is shaping up into something
terrifying.
Director Ruben Fleischer is promising a horror-tinged
film with a Venom who isn't afraid to get
bloody and chomp on a few heads.
"So many snacks, so little time."
All signs point to Sony getting things right
with their second crack at the deadly symbiote
and we'll see just how right when Venom
hits theaters on October 5th.